hey guys it's just date and today we're
gonna be talking about some of the
things that I wish I would have had when
I was going to college it's crazy how
much time has passed
but it's also crazy how much technology
has changed in those short years and by
short I mean like 14 or 15 years one of
the things that a stayed consistent
through all of those years even through
college is I always went to Best Buy for
all of my tech all of my gaming needs
which makes this video even more
exciting for me because I actually got
to partner with Best Buy to make this
for you guys so a huge thank you to Best
Buy for sponsoring this video I'm making
this possible and if you guys have been
around for a long time you guys know
that this is not new information that
I'm such a huge fan so this is so so
exciting in preparing for this video I
was kind of going down memory lane and
just thinking about all of the things
that happened in college and how much
easier things are now as far as
technology everything has become so much
more accessible look we didn't even have
cameras then like we had to rent them or
check them out because an actual decent
camera then was so incredibly expensive
that it was just not attainable for any
college student now you can shoot a
feature film on your phone another rate
thing that Best Buy has is student deals
so if you are a student and you are
going back to school they have a bunch
of exclusive deals that will get you
guys the best prices on tech all you
have to do is text 3 3 2 2 1 1 to sign
up another thing that's great is they
have fast store pickup so a lot of times
I don't have time to wait for something
to be shipped you could just go online
look it up and then you can pick it up
in the store and they also have a price
match guarantee so if you do find
something that is cheaper somewhere else
you can go in and say hello can you
match this price that was me holding up
a flier or something I don't know let's
go ahead in the Best Buy now and see
what kind of things I found
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the one that I was looking at
online so this is the Asus 15.6 inch
gaming laptop and if you guys are trying
to convince your parents into getting
you a gaming laptop parents you can do
more on it than just play games that
just means it's really super powerful
and incredible but they'll be able to do
their homework faster but it also means
you can play games too so don't lie
thank you our first purchase so I'm kind
of looking for a crossover bag something
that I can use for my computer but also
for putting my cameras and stuff in this
looks very nice actually
there's a lot of places to put things
I'm gonna do this one unless I find
another one that I like more one of the
things that I definitely wish I had in
college was a printer of my own because
I always have to go to the computer labs
and it was such a stressful situation
everyone was printing stuff but this is
really exciting because I saw this one
and this is the HP tango X wireless
printer but love about this is it's a
smart printer so it does connect to a le
X
I can kind of hide it so it doesn't look
like a printer so if you are in a
smaller space like a dorm or an
apartment you can kind of neatly tuck it
away it can expire with li connect it to
your smartphone so you can basically
take it anywhere print and scan which is
so amazing
not only what I'd love to have it in
college but I'm going to enjoy having it
in my adult life yes okay here they are
so these are the Turtle Beach Atlas
elite headphones of course they're for
gaming but you could also use them for
you know listening to audiobooks or
whatever it is that you want to convince
your parents and tell them yeah this is
important I need this for my homework oh
my gosh it's so loud can you hear me I
mean can I hear you I can't hear you
height can't wait to listen to
audiobooks so smart home tech is
something that I am extremely into and
we definitely did not have any of this
stuff when I went to school but I am
such a huge fan of Philips you you can
control your lights the color
temperature everything so it can really
change the entire ambiance of your dorm
where you have so many different things
to pick from now so I'm gonna go with
one of these light strips I love these
because you can put them under your beds
behind your TV so you can really put
these anywhere and I'm also gonna grab
two oh they're on sale too with these
philips hue light bulbs thank you these
are my absolute favorite hard drives
these are the samsung portable
solid-state drives this is a t5 these
are so fast like I added almost all of
my videos directly off of these drives
now depending upon what you're doing you
might not need a drive that is this fast
but I think a portable hard drive is
something that everyone should invest in
you should always make sure that you
have your files backed up especially if
you were writing papers or something
like that and if you don't save things
on a hard drive to make sure you're
saving in the cloud somewhere email the
files to yourself like you do not want
to be stuck with a crashed computer or a
crashed hard drive and then you lose all
of your hard work because I've
definitely been there and it isn't
I'm always gonna be like are you going
back to school or are you gonna start
joining an eSports team both mom let's
go take a look at the coffee makers
Keurig has a coffee and latte maker this
would have first of all saved me so much
money at Starbucks because I could have
made my own lattes I'm so happy we're on
a mission looking for a surge protector
because one of the things that we always
ran into in school especially living in
a dorm is we needed outlets we have some
regular power strips and then this one's
an actual surge protectors so we're
gonna get this one all right let's check
out I think I got everything I need plus
a few extras let's go home and unbox
here's our laptop let's open it up I did
not tell you guys how much I wish that I
had a PC when I was in college most of
the programs that we used for all on PC
I didn't even have a laptop at all so I
spent so much time in the computer lab I
could've spent it at home with my
roommate who I actually got along with
so this is the asus 15.6 inch gaming
laptop this has AMD risin 7 16 gigs of
ram this is a nice finish on the top of
it look at you so of course this will be
powerful enough that you can play games
on it and of course powerful enough to
do many of your homework I do remember I
think was my second year of college so
when I started really getting back into
video games again the first year I
focused so much on my work which yes is
very important if I would have passed
this
kind of gentleman work and play games at
the same time sort of next up we have
the turtle beach elite atlas these are
some headphones that I definitely wish
that I would have had let's open them up
oh wow
he's look nice oh yeah
these are super comfy this is something
that I definitely wish I would have had
it was a printer and this is actually
something that I wish that I currently
would have had in my life I am so
excited to test this printer out the one
that I have is such an absolute
nightmare so this is honestly it is so
perfect look at you so Ivy Apple
downloaded and this is pretty much set
up and ready to go so I'm gonna put this
over my office and I'm gonna try the
first test print are you ready
oh did you know that there's a printer
here
you probably didn't because of its
little hide-and-seek cover look how
awesome this thing is so this is where
you put the paper in I've got some of
this little printer photo paper ready
we're gonna print a picture of you and
I'm gonna put this bright from the app
so here it is it Auto changed the paper
size and now we're just gonna hit print
have you ever seen anything more amazing
Maddie you're gonna be coming out of
there is that you ready it's a picture
of you we went on the hike the other day
look at you this actually looks really
good it's so great are you over it but
okay goodbye
I really like this printer a lot it also
has an ink of subscription so depending
on how much you print a month you can
get a subscription and it will only send
you ink when you need it these things
are so incredible I have them all over
my house and I don't even think this
kind of technology was around when I was
in school but what's great about this is
it can kind of turn your dorm room or
your house or wherever it is that you
are and give you a much more ambient
feel like you can change the color of
the lights you could put these basically
anywhere the light strips are probably
my favorite they come oh it's just this
little power adapter this has double
sided tape on it so you couldn't show us
peel off the tape and stick it wherever
you want this is something that I
actually picked up on the way out so
this is a silicon carrying case for your
ear pods I always am trying to find my
ear pods in my bag and I love having a
little clip to just cook everything onto
so you can just pop your air pods right
into this click them to your keys your
gym bag and never lose them you can
never have enough surge protectors in
your dorm or your apartment or your
house I'm constantly always looking for
outlets I travel with these things
you're gonna need one of these is a nice
nickel yes maybe is it brushed nickel it
might just be nickel
[Music]
so the reason that I picked this is
something that I wish that I would have
had when I was in college is because
honestly I spent so much money in coffee
shops and this actually would have saved
me so much money a latte for like four
or five bucks but I could've made my own
I know so this is great it's definitely
good I wish they would
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this video and
again a huge thank you to Best Buy for
sponsoring this this was so much fun to
make and it was so fun kind of going
back and reliving my college experience
while I was shopping let me know in the
comments below if there are any tips
that you have for future college
students and especially if you are in
college what is something that you wish
you would have known before you went to
school I'll be looking forward to
reading your comments and I will see you
guys in the next video bye
[Music]